citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for us to celebrate 4th of July reject
Style with secret Invasion Episode
thrust today John thank you for joining
us how are you absolutely I am great
he's forcing it Coy how are you you see
the thing about America is we secretly
invade a lot of places so this is pretty
fun all right friends
ladies and gentlemen if you didn't catch
the memo the three of us we're going to
be having a real rejects Comic-Con panel
that's right every movie studio
abandoned ship at Comic-Con because they
heard we're having a panel that day so
if you're attending Comic-Con or if
you're on the fence you should come
attend our panel and we will of course
love to hang out with you that's the way
we roll so ladies and gentlemen before
we go into this leave a like that would
be great also subscribe click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for episode 4 is up here on
the Chanel and as always full
interaction watching long resync up with
your own copy of secret Invasion
available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page covers several things
exclusive over there with highlights and
watch alongs included thank you to all
who have joined me in so many pledges
don't miss out on all the fun over there
let's get to it
thank you
and AI put this together
[Music]
honey where's my super suit
[Laughter]
be careful they always tuck it in the
crotch it's a terrible terrifying
terrible tell you Cheddar Bob that
nobody learned why did you join the
resistance Beto I didn't want our people
to keep running not good enough
you joined the same reason I did
the awesome headquarters
time to make some poly juice potions
now at the council meeting I told you I
had a plan for taking Earth as our own I
sent three operatives to infiltrate the
Royal Navy the Royal Navy huh
the heroes of Earth
will react
no they won't I can't afford them for
this episode
become super ourselves oh super they are
doing it
we change powers
mirror cologne
that's where it all happens
ah the one good de-aging effect it's
like his is so good wanna sit here while
you wait
VAR
this should put Jacob's men on their
heels
Black Widow
this new face of yours is
[Laughter]
Commander station and operatives cannot
be our unit doesn't exist Fury that
means I don't work for you
yeah let's go that's an intriguing
possibility
[Music]
make sure you got enough food and water
because that my friends looks a hell of
a lot like world war three Shooter
McGavin even the broken clocks right
twice a day
good morning
Fury's Republican
two times
right I never harbored any Illusions
about the necessity of you going away
but staying away
that leaves a mark
is green
still away right now any plans for the
downtime
well you know I never cared much for
golf spycraft I'm thinking I may take up
Revenge
let's go
even the books are crazy sorting books
by color is haunting some of the touches
are a little funny production designers
understood the assignment just when I
thought I had gotten past the Heartbreak
you came back in the blip
yeah I thought we were going to undo all
the pain together
go back to the way we were but no
I love that they touched this topic I
really do really needed to I've been
vanished again only this time it was
voluntary
if you're interested in who I became in
your second absence
I became me whether the choice was there
when you kept disappearing as if you
were never really here in the first
place
great
how many men did you sleep with
hahaha
they're wearing yellow and blue to note
their division in the colors of green
something important
nope
up the phone oh she intentionally left
that
[Music]
phone's a scroll someone told the cops
where we were headed
normally we know that
Brogan I'd imagine when they asked him
where they could find you he was forced
to make an educated guess is that what
you do
I'd lie
I'm a good liar
I really like him a lot it was broken
it was weaker than you thought I feel
like a great liar wouldn't say I'm a
great liar you know that's like
bad bad skills of a liar is to let you
in on that online
Sight Four negatives make a positive I'm
such a good liar that's why you can
trust me your father called for a party
apparently we mean about you
parent-teacher conference
yeah whoa his hand looks huge
unplane will be at Neptune's coordinates
2 200 hours felt like a leak
don't do it I feel like he said it just
to see if you'd legit choice between
having my story told in ink or Avenue
Written in Blood I choose blood all day
long
great he's great Brave
you asked Nepali so let's party shall we
come on well you're parrying right now
well you just get an empty cup I like a
little bit of espresso with my sugar
are you honestly puzzled as to why the
council would prefer me as general over
the likes of you you want to be very
very careful now you should be grateful
that I haven't sent that back to you in
a body bag yet oh
yes don't Ezra Miller him
[Music]
even knowing the scene was the scene it
was still that was awesome all these
Miss Koreans know it's murder you don't
understand the first thing about humans
we're pretty awful they're in their most
formidable
when they're threatened
that's right do you think I'm Gonna Let
You continue this war under the cover of
anonymity I'm going to tell every Army
on Earth who it is that's attacking them
you'll lose the element of a surprise
too much info Taylor's too much info we
will show them we who haven't been
infected
by your sickness
guy stays with me there is it yeah
[Music]
now until the end of time my daughter's
name stays out of your mouth
oh you got it
oh
John Wick over here
in this show still surprises me man that
was so painful to say yeah
oh I'm sorry no all right
I believe this is yours what'd you do
kindly old guy
has he already been super scrolled up
that hand that doesn't seem like a thing
they can do yet Power number one
regeneration
your dad was unreasonable
PTA made him good horribly you hurt my
hand he embarrassed me in front of all
the different me's anyone that could say
what you said to me asked that
I have the bowl to come up in here in a
hospital
what do you hear that English breakfast
night or you need inquire optimize
well-being no I think it's a pretty big
deal here for that right has he
swallowed his food now no it's enough
all of that with one bite script
supervisor having a heart attack you've
got a line on this growl that's up in
the US government it's understood that
you think that implies that I should
just sort of leap up and
just to help you like that it's nice to
go inside I'm gonna need you to you know
use your words
say what words
help me tell us because I am useless
without you
I love you too Nick
we can't touch foreheads here
whoever this is you shouldn't have this
number
first I want an apology I just gave
hahaha
because you rather rudely attached a
nasty bug to my beloved hoot oh she
found it who has a new name now Nicholas
Fury
pack now
name is Commodore Robert Fairbanks can I
get a photo and a dress should I tell
him you're on your way yeah tell him
that
you know what I I don't get the whole
dog thing what's to get dog's a man's
best friend
it's acceptable to clean up the other
guy's poo cleaning up your poop for the
last 30 something years oh that's rich
that's really what you think that the
whole time we've known each other you've
been cleaning up my mess did you not see
far from home
you were just a bench woman nobody in a
dumpy field office in Shield
you know we fed you more dirt and Intel
then you could have uncovered on your
own in a lifetime
every time you were promoted inside
Shield
we did that every terror attack you
prevented how much do you leverage with
dirt no one else in the world had access
to we did that
you're smart and capable guy for you
nobody questions that
your life got a hell of a lot more
Charmed once I came into it and you know
something
I don't even need to hear a bloody thank
you
it was my pleasure mate
I stopped four we're here
remember Bob the guy that's got lots of
nuclear attacks I'm sorry I didn't
realize that no that's because you were
too busy riding her we did that wave
you got any more abuse you want to hurl
my way I love them so much and then I
get to say we did that
and Bob's your uncle you're so this is
the scenes episode this is great oh the
show's so good with dialogue so much
heart you in position worry about your
own damn self do me a favor Fury don't
ever change
so I just left you
[Music]
a lot of noise
that was just actual bullets I think you
just killed some skrulls Saint your
mama's Nick Fury show
grandpappy or whatever
that's the kid who's going to launch
world war three I was busy kicking Bob's
ass second floor last door down the hall
can't be there I'm kind of worried that
we didn't see him say that yeah some
doesn't seem right
uh he noticed too nobody calls me Nick
Bob
this is not a negotiation Bob
[Applause]
to find something to time up
your thing boss
thanks for saving my life Fury no
problem Taylor anytime
what you're working on over there Bob oh
boy if you're afraid of going against
gravity I could protect you you couldn't
protect yourself coming through that
door
fair point we would have stood by you
proudly so stand with me now you're too
late enough for this oh whoa three
seconds to give me that code or I'm
gonna aim higher or or maybe lower oh
you got minutes to figure out that code
if we can't make your friend here tell
us
tracers like you are the reason people
have been walking in exile for 30 years
you sickened me
shut gonna be man
shut up I can't even keep your
daughter's loyalty or is she the
spineless trait of feeding you
information
whoa
that is an effect
foreign
[Music]
God it must be so hard to find
information in here you got it
okay now run
yeah a boat exercise code word
Zachary aboard launch is that the name
of the Sun
this was a dumpster fire
this whole mission gotta be hard for you
to be fighting with him when deep down
in your bones you believe in what he's
doing
I'm not with gravic because I'm with you
the truck is green there
whoa
oh no who could have a sinner there's a
common don't turn around
no
you look at me
are you a leader of Scrolls
or a worse
or a butcher
uh they just kill Emilia Clark
oh
that's Maria Hill and disguises a scroll
in disguises melee Clark
another skull sacrifice themselves for
it's a mystery maybe another scroll was
posing as her I think she's just fine
Red Scarf guy
give you some time alone Jason Bourne's
passport
your mission you went through all that
to get it done I feel like she could get
one professional in her house
St James Church one hour
I need to speak to graphic yeah well
you're talking to me
uh-oh confirmed on channels and scroll
yeah it sounded like Don Cheadle
oh damn oh damn so they've like embedded
her with Fury who's not a double agent
except Nick Fury that's gonna be so
heartbreaking man who do we trust who do
we trust he's Amelia Clark dead I think
so okay well first impression thoughts I
really enjoyed the episode as per huge
we got some things we got to talk about
for sure
um and it was really entertaining it was
faster paced than the other ones which
when you're shooting at midnight is
convenient because you're like oh dang I
gotta edit this so shorter episode all
right then on the flip side is just a
viewer I'm like liked it before when it
was a bit of a slower burn and then some
of the because there's some moments here
that I thought especially towards the
end when it came to like it was the
plane gonna hit the submarine though
those moments I thought if there if it
was more along the lines of the tone and
pacing of the other ones then I think
the suspense of that might have been
more felt and more palpable however uh
overall I still found the episode to be
very entertaining and there's some
things to dive into so I'm gonna kick it
off right here with uh not being selfish
and going what was your overall thought
oh yes no yeah I quite enjoyed this
episode and I liked how Reliant it was
on yeah like you know just character
scenes back and forth discussions and
things like that uh yeah this is I guess
the one thing is like I was never really
that concerned that like World War III
was about to start so I'm waiting for
like the macro Stakes to really like
kick in and start to feel like they're
vital but I really love the character
work and the immediate you know story
that they're telling us through these
scenes that were weaving I think the
personal stuff the the sort of on the
ground stuff is really engaging and yeah
now I just want to kind of have the you
know big massive Stakes feel like
they're also vital definitely definitely
I agree with all those points question
they said super scroll they did uh
somebody's favorite dialogue in the MCU
and I feel like the MCU gets a lot of
crap for just being like oh this is
shiny this is not you know weighted this
is all these things and even though I
also didn't assume World War III would
break out episode three of a show on
Disney plus I did feel like it was a
show that allowed weight because of the
dialogue this was a show that has so
much personality there's a lot of really
fascinating stuff with Mendelson where
his insecurity and Samuel Jackson's
insecurity are both so beautifully
bouncing off each other because of their
30 year friendship I assume Ben
Mendelson and Sam Jackson in real life
have not known each other 30 years had I
not known them as actors until this show
like say there were two unknowns I'd be
like I bet these guys went to college
together that's how good they seem and
that's the writing that's the way
they're shooting it that's the caliber
of these actors so personally for me
this is really really impressive scene
work which is what I'm loving out of
this tone and this feels more like a
comic to me I love Comics dialogue you
read a comic you don't watch a comic
you're in a comic so this is wonderful
yeah I agree it's like their chemistry
together is like a buddy comedy but
deeper than that it's more nuanced
instead of just the surface levels of
like oh we give each other you know
it's you could feel a real history that
they're working through some and
yeah they're actually talking with each
other so I think that's great and uh we
definitely want to talk a little bit
more about that but the first thing we
gotta talk about obviously they just Don
cheadle's in the credits yeah so his
voice on the phone was either either
roady's a dick or
I would love that scroll he's just
secretly been addicted he's just a jerk
what crazy ramifications that is for
armor Wars yes because that was made
from a show into a movie uh I imagine
metal tie into Thunderbolts with a world
that hates and fears them coming for the
X-Men there's gonna be a lot of distrust
there's going to be a lot of wait you
were this high up in government you were
like number three to the president and
you were infiltrated you were an alien
how do we trust you and then yes maybe
that leads to armor Wars and then
obviously Thunderbolts maybe his
retaliation to that then we found it
they're bad guys and yet again the X-Men
like it's all a big Powder Keg and I'm
really loving how they're doing that
that's true I mean it makes me think
about the ramifications of the
conversation that took place between Don
Cheadle and Sam Jackson in episode two
because and I will just interchange
between calling them by their sexual
names and to their character names uh
because in in that conversation you know
he was saying like I'm shutting you down
Fury pretty much but it wasn't
attempting to kill him or anything like
that so if it is roadie could have just
been trying to protect him in some ways
you know like protect him and keep him
out of Harm's Way that's what I am
taking it as yeah exactly
um or you know if he is a scroll he
might see him as a threat and being like
if there's one person capable of taking
us down it would be Nick Fury so we
gotta stop him you know so it does have
you kind of uh
Ponder what some of the objectives and
motivations might be but John yes are
you feeling about Don Cheadle AKA
Terence Howard uh it explains some guys
the armor Wars is clearly going to be
about Roadie carpet bombing Slovakia
it's true he did promise yeah I mean
that's the thing that people have been
speculating for a while and I think it
would be an interesting entanglement
just because Yao Roadie has worn a
couple of faces
uh keep my daughter's name out of your
mouth uh yeah I'm I think that's fun I
think it's a fun Prospect and I bet
that's something that they hid in plain
sight in this episode to make you go
like okay the the real shape-shifting
game is now a foot I mean we've seen you
know Graphics crew you know do their
Sinister like ooh we're all you know we
are all graphic I am Spartacus but uh
you know I think part of the big thing
people are waiting for part of the fun
end games of this Beyond you know the
more sort of mature Marvel is which of
our heroes are you know gonna be Scrolls
or when do they become Scrolls and all
that stuff and we've already had Everett
Ross entangled in that debate and now we
have you know the prospect Don Cheadle
so I don't know I think that'll be good
I'll give him a lot of fun to play with
too I also think it's going to be really
fun to watch how the show develops into
what are the ramifications on the film
side because a lot of these Disney Plus
shows haven't impacted the films that
much but the next thing is the Marvels
which is a sequel to Captain Marvel as
much as this is this is a sequel to
Captain Marvel and end game because of
the dialogue because the conversations
but it's obviously a Captain Marvel
sequel so it's really great to have this
in between the martyrs you know so I'm
really curious about that impact I just
hope the screenwriters of the movie were
able to get the scripts ahead of time to
watch it yeah no time no notes that's
the that's the main thing we need to
care about scratch you know
um so is Emilia Clarke dead now yes um I
think so I really do I really think her
Casting was genius to have it be like
three episodes do you do you want me to
proceed with why I truly believe she's
not dead please you are everyone here is
setting themselves up for a minor
spoiler in case oh is there you know a
thing I know a thing only because
I spent a good amount of time editing
your interview with the director so I
got very familiar with the footage
has not aired yet
that's so funny spoiler alert footage
spoiler alert the official trailers
[Music]
a good trailer without a spoiler oh
that's so funny I think it's
intentionally they're trying to do a
cliffhanger here to make you go oh wow
stunt casting um but no I I definitely
am like there's so much trailer footage
that my mind went to I didn't film 100
million dollars unless unless they are
all deleted scenes at this point we
filmed 12 different sequences that we
used yeah I definitely don't think she's
dead due to that fact they did a good
job in switching them and they did a
good job setting it up where I'm like in
dear to you but I like that they got
this out of the way of of you know the
reveal and graphic finding out uh you
know like I've confirmed you are a
lighter and getting that out of the way
so we can get to the meat because the
meat of the show seems to really be
about exploring the relationships and as
much as I like her being a double agent
it's going to allow us to probably have
I mean I haven't seen footage of this
necessarily I imagine though that it
would lead to her being able to have
more conversations with Talos which I'd
love to hear yeah and that's more the
thing that I really want to get to can
we talk about how great gravic is
graphic is he's like man I feel like he
did such good work here feel like he'll
kill you at any moment yeah it really
has that Vibe and his energy in that
museum scene like we've seen him very
subdued I like seeing the big theatrical
like where he's presenting he's like the
blood versus the art and the ink like
all of that was so presentational and
that was beautiful we haven't really
seen that side of him yet and as as the
resistance is rising so what's his
performance yes it is being reflected in
who he is John what do you think about
Nick Fury his wife I'll give you 10
points if you remember her name uh is it
oh it's like Priscilla or something we
are one click away from seeing the cast
list is it Priscilla it's a drumroll
yes
those points are coming Fury's wife yeah
please John what are your thoughts
I really liked their scene together
early on in the episode I thought that
back and forth than the uncovering of
like the grief surrounding Nick Fury's
avoidance of the trauma of the blip and
all that stuff but yes jumping to the
end of the episode her with the safety
deposit box and the special gun uh I'm
well I don't know like you guys
I think she was picking up a mission
right right like she was going there and
but but she already had her phone on her
she could have just a grab her gun yeah
you need this gun
uh but yeah I think that that is also
kind of setting up I'm very curious
because I think they're setting up us up
for some kind of emotional conflict I
think you have the Talos and Gaia thing
which is a much easier to understand
sort of divide between like why they're
on different sides of the line sure
thing whereas I feel like with Nick and
Priscilla you could have some more harsh
and entangled sort of gordian knot of
reasoning as to why she might be
involved with graphic and and the you
know what do you call their group
whatever you call them you know maybe
there's some kind of Leverage they have
over her maybe she has been like spying
on him and supplying information on Nick
Fury and maybe you know this will lead
us to some kind of Greater reveal about
how the Nick we've seen walking around
isn't actually the real Nick
I'm wondering yeah is the Nick on the
spaceship still Nick
there's been inconsistent limping and
Nick Fury is too good of an actor for
that what I like about the especially
what they do with the Priscilla scene
early on
comparing it to the reasoning that Talos
gives to
um Nick about why he's siding here
because I'm with you where you get the
scene in Priscilla and clearly she's on
the opposing side that Nick is on and in
the big in the beginning part of this
episode she's almost like blaming him
for why she's on the opposing side yeah
you know like she had to become herself
and leave him and her side yeah and
fully invest yeah in the scroll you know
cause good character work it's really
good character and Talos is seen in the
car
they've said both to lost well Graphics
says Talos
when I kept hearing it I was like I
guess it's Talos I haven't seen Talos
forever
so Taylor
is that the British pronunciation what's
going on tylose so Talos uh I really
like in the a retroactive importance of
skrull's element I always love when
shared storytelling can make an impact
bigger and his his entire descriptor of
like no no you owe me the scrolls are
like you're Nick Fury was some of the
most genius retroactive importance
writing like that scene by itself made
me like this girl's more than all of
Captain Marvel like that was truly an
impactful dialogue and that's that's
what writing can be for me is like I'd
rather see that than a hundred crazy
girl War fight scenes I'd rather see
that than like that gave you so much
juice in Marvel and that's the power of
good writing so I want that's why I want
this grounded stuff because that now I
want to re-watch Captain Marvel now I'm
really excited to watch the Marvels and
it's all because of a dialogue scene
with a great actor yeah well that's I
love how Talos is like core need is to
be appreciated
someone to care about him doing the work
listen I know it's shitty but I've been
holding it down
please just look at like a real
relationship I just want to be
appreciated yeah and then Mendelson
crushes it without being whiny he's just
like lovely it is so sensitive well
that's I think that's the great thing
about this show like this episode I was
really sitting there and relishing in
the combination of yeah quality writing
and
performers who can really really like
walk around in it and make it feel 100
like the scenes between Kingsley benedir
and Ben mendelsohn are great and like
Kingsley benedir has this great draw
this sort of like almost lackadaisical
quality that even persists when he does
you know kind of arch into something
more showy and more flamboyant
um but yeah just like the little ways in
which they're like kind of like when he
kind of gets up on him and he's like
touching him and he's kind of like
choking on him in that one scene in the
in when they're having the talk and then
yeah between Ben Mendelson and Nick Fury
there's just like such great like open
emotional back and forth the violence
too man that hand I was like epic I
guess they could justify it by it heals
right away but damn that is Groot that
is Gory like that it's gross yeah yeah
it's and is there some blood effects too
yeah I hate that it's literally hearing
at the flesh there that's the new thing
the disturbing Gore the upholstery
already coming Disney plus it's already
begun here we are wait all right well
one of our keywords is theories so uh
I would uh also like to confirm
s episode confirmed uh I do think the
super Scrolls will be uh more than one
episode so I'd imagine the end of next
episode we get our first super scroll
and that's episode five and six yeah uh
my other theory is that someone that is
an Avenger is gonna be revealed as a
Skrill in the fifth episode I think
they'll do that yeah I think I think
we're gonna get something huge like
that's gonna be like a big like oh my
God yeah I don't feel like they're
interested at all in doing that I think
we'll get a like an internet Buzzy like
bull like where it's like oh my god did
you see I think it's gonna come out
yeah
they didn't know they find out by the
show live character was this girl
everyone has been recast fenroll's a
scrubber all day
yeah Edward Norton okay Terrence Howard
appears and goes to Maine and they just
cut
I just want to hear one main and I guess
Maria Hill truly is dead yeah tart out
here for a scroll yeah there's some
answers in the
um no I mean what are your theories uh
my theories is that uh your theories
will come true
my theory is that some of the theories
are gonna be wrong but a couple of the
theories all right are gonna be a little
bit kind of accurate but not 100 my
mind's blown with the way the reaction
is edited that is a breakdown in and of
itself of the episode uh you we clearly
talked about the ending so that's been
explained yes
um we're re-recaptain is that the
headline now yeah those videos just try
to make sure we have uh all our SEO
taken care of so we're not live when the
ending isn't confusing and someone's
like
yeah what is yeah do you mean the movie
ended and then we left the theater my
closest friends do them ending explains
they're great dominating Us in views
right now I'm not saying they don't get
clicks I'm saying they don't get
Integrity well and uh Easter eggs
from
the restaurant they went to was the
Shawarma restaurant at the beginning did
you guys notice that oh I'm bullshitting
no I was like there's no way I was like
replaying all that in my head wait a
second hey there's no I'm lining uh
there's graphic like Irish uh it doesn't
matter
all righty guys what did you think about
this episode hey list your nitpicks down
below uh thank you that's the new thing
we say Now list your nitpicks down below
um subscribe leave a like keep a lookout
for our Comic-Con panel just go to every
single day and then to go I don't know
when they're gonna be here but I'm going
I'm going every pedal until I find them
send this to the page
Crying Ryan Smith I want to take a peek
at Kevin Meek Adrian Tims just wants to
live in The Sims keep it real nagas
Heather gear pouring her life away by
Downing beer Ian Simon loves the films
of Doug Lyman Songhai Glover killed his
brother Kayla The King's Speech Alan
Ling refused to throw the ring into
Mordor you'll be hurting after a run-in
with Logan Burton Tiara broke my
friend's heart his name was Kevin
Herrera Eric comic-con's
1939. kousy coosey said my skin looks
Lucy Lucy put on my x-ray specs when I
look at Nick X Juan Longoria shut down
fangoria get a whiff of that fragrant
Cliff Rodriguez Master T always has
yellow pee looking like a snackster
Lorenzo Baxter differently sane tripped
a woman with a at Kane Lauren American
Horse conquering an obstacle course of
course simply faded makes me feel
berated Simeon Justice 94. Rosie Beatty
so goddamn Shady Colin insert a rhyme
with Joseph Stalin or Ballin I feel like
we've done Stalin but either way I'm
Falling For You Phillip J Smith Jr
wishes my death would come sooner Jen
Smith is not a Ken she's a Barbie
Melanie LeBlanc beat up a monk
good they had a coming all right guys
well I hope you appreciated John's a
hyper sarcasm and my sincerity in this
shout out today always thank you guys
for being here you guys rock your all
great human beings ignore John's cruelty
uh yeah you don't have to you know hold
me accountable for the cruel actions
I hate everything except you guys
foreign